[Music]
to an artist willing to experiment codes
and algorithms can be just as creative
tools as the paintbrush
here are four stories to prove that
beauty has no bounds when art meets
technology
when an interactive artwork
forms an engagement
with people in the audience
you can watch a sort of conversation
develop the artwork's not really fully
realized until those interactions have
been allowed to occur
my name's jeffrey drake brockman and i'm
a cybernetics artist
i work in the most isolated city in the
world perth western australia
for a long time i had two parallel lives
i was an i.t guy a computer programmer
and i was also a painter
i kept the whole idea of art completely
separate from computation and that just
sort of led to a crisis i thought what
am i doing who am i kidding
so i let it in and suddenly i was making
artworks which were robotic
cybernetics is about
interaction
it can be made out of any kind of
technology you can use electronics
computers even clockwork to enable
conversations to take place between
people and artworks
for me the whole point of using
technology in art is to make an artwork
interactive with interactivity you can
get deep audience engagement people look
at a piece for hours on end instead of
just a minute
when i complete an artwork i like to
watch it respond to its audience i watch
to see how the play between the artwork
and the audience develops sometimes i
saw people who were treating the artwork
as though it was a person they were
smiling at it waving to it
talking to it i thought how far can we
take this
the part that i love most of all is when
it's done when the vision is realized
when i can set the artwork free and
watch you interact with people it's
actually doing what it's meant to do and
creating what it's meant to create
[Music]
the main difficulties of working with
any vulnerable or fragile work of
cultural heritage is the respect you
have to have for that object
[Music]
technology is at a point right now
where we can record the surface of an
object down to fractions of a millimeter
and it's through this kind of
understanding that allows you to
communicate across time and across
cultures
the task of heritage protection and
preservation is a real challenge
the mission of factom foundation
is to record cultural heritage
so in the event that there's a disaster
or an accident we have the data to know
what was there exactly as it is
we're pioneering a number of methods
to return that information into the
physical world
we're doing cnc milling we're doing 3d
printing but we're trying to go beyond
that
a facsimile of the borgarini chapel
the facsimile of the tomb of truth and
carmen in the valley of the kings
an exact facsimile of verenese's wedding
at canada
[Applause]
the biggest project that's going on at
the moment is an exact facsimile of the
tomb of seti the first which will be
given to the people of egypt as soon as
it's finished
200 years ago the concern was not one of
preservation the concern was one of
indiana jones and discovery and
excitement and cultural
acquisitions
the tombs in the valley of the kings
lasted successfully for three thousand
three and a half thousand years
but since they've been visited they
start to decline and decay rapidly
i think the facsimile is opening up a
whole new level of possibility for
display preservation conservation
restoration communication dissemination
of what's important about these objects
if only we can preserve it like it is
and document it and hand it on to future
generations then there's hope
[Music]
i see my work as woven into the fabric
of cities
these soft fibers
move and adapt to wind and light and
rain and they are a way of being
they are about interconnectedness
i'm janet eckelman i'm an artist
i bring
sculpture and
form and light into the public realm so
that we can
literally change the spaces that we live
in in cities
my sculpture has traveled to five
continents it takes an incredible team
to create one of these sculptures i am
working with computer scientists and
artisans and aeronautical and structural
engineers all over the world
this part is hanging the way we want it
to hang on the diamond my studio is
where we incubate ideas
some of my newest work i'm using
data sets from science whether it's
human action or an earthquake and
tsunami
to reveal
our relationship with the world
and then i just start sketching whether
it's with a pen or a paintbrush
then we start to model it in three
dimensions in the computer and we also
make physical models
they begin as raw fiber that is braided
into twine and rope put onto bobbins and
loomed using machines and the ropes are
spliced by hand
to take the work and install it in the
city is a whole nother set of artistry
the piece comes together as a single
sewn garment for the city
my work is about the dynamic nature of
life
and it's always unfolding
during the day the colors of the
sculpture
change slightly as sunlight changes
at night i'm projecting colored light
that is very slowly gradually changing
it's never the same piece and you and
the person you come to see it with might
have completely different experiences
the work invites people to engage with
it
[Music]
people who are not in stem and kind of
have an outside look at software
development sometimes don't understand
how truly creative it is
reading lines of code is like reading
poetry it's an art form in itself and
it's a culture of
really bringing ideas to light
diamonds
i started coding when i was nine years
old and i've been dancing since i think
i was able to walk
my father is a dancer so it was in my
blood so there's one egg where mateo is
on his own
so i had a plan in life
i had a direction i was going to be a
professional dancer
everything was lined up
and then i got cancer
it changed the whole path of my life
while i was in recovery i'm not really
good at sitting still so i was writing
software from the hospital bed i've
gotten almost obsessed like it was
something that just kept me going and
when i came back home
i wanted to dance again
i was in the midst of trying to find
ways to mix dance and technology and
that's when i came up with the idea of
the light suits and wirelessly
programming them to make really amazing
visual art
all right i'm gonna stop at this queue
when it starts
let's just see if this is right before
they start
we were
up hours and hours and hours writing the
software and
trying different things and it was it
was a lot of fun the end product is as
simple as me pressing one button and the
lights turn on and another button and
they change color and a few buttons and
a sequence happens
we were performing in public spaces and
the more positive reactions we got the
more confident i was to just go for it
and just a few months after that we were
on america's got talent and
the rest is kind of history it's
groundbreaking what you do it's
incredible you create everything from
zero
and it's just brilliant
we've worked with um chris brown
deathcat for cutie
christine aguilera black eyed peas
then we also had
our own show that has been on in the
heart of broadway for several years and
is touring both nationally and
internationally
it can go on and on
the future for illuminae is definitely
education
i want to be able to have students from
different backgrounds work and
collaborate together because if you
learn how to respect people who do
something different than you and have
them respect you back that kind of skill
set will really take you farther in life
you